[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Marissa
Is With Us in Atlanta Hi Marissa welcome
to the Ramsey
Show Hi how are you great what's
up um so my question is uh with the
student loan repayment starting uh my
parents and I like many others are a
little overwhelmed trying to figure out
our approach um so when we took out
loans for my school my parents didn't
have great credit and I didn't have a
line of credit so they took out a plus
loan and I'm the third kid that went to
school in our family so they have Plus
loans for all three of us and then I
have my separate subsidized and
unsubsidized loan under my name my
question is should I have the Parent
PLUS Loan transferred to my name and
refinance it to take the burden off of
my parents um because we're just trying
to figure out the best way to approach
it and right now it's just way too much
for them to
handle if you can pay the payment just
pay the
payment myself or my parents well you
said your parents can't handle it and
you were going to move it to your name
which would mean you're paying the
payment
right yeah I mean I so I graduated two
years ago um with a health science
degree and I don't make a ton of money
right now you my original so I'm I just
got a new job I'm going to make $23 an
hour and then I also um have like a side
nannying gig as just like a
transportation to school um but my
original plan was to like go to medical
school do that whole thing and then once
I graduated I was overwhelmed already
with the amount of debt that I had how
much de do you
have so under my name I have 27 ,000 but
then my the parent plus loan is I think
up to like
80,000
okay um well it does no it it does not
add any value to move it to your name
you can't pay
it you don't make
enough you're struggling to pay your
27 am I missing
something I just with my parents having
three kids kids it just all kind of fell
on them and I think with us being the
first generation college kids we didn't
really know that much going into it um I
don't think that we really did the best
research when we were going into school
to try to find our best option um and
so I I there's I appreciate you owning
it it's obvious mistakes have been made
yes you got you got $7,000 in student
loan debt and you're making $23 an hour
so obviously mistakes have been made
there's not you know but but that's you
know water under the bridge at this
point if you call me up you said I'm
making 100,000 a year I'm about to knock
this 27 out in a heartbeat and I'm going
to take this 80 over and knock it out
for Mom and Dad uh I would tell you just
to pay it while it's in mom and dad's
name and take the the mathematical
burden off of them but no reason to
legally put it in your name it doesn't
serve any purpose go ahead and knock it
out but in your case
you can a little you're going to have to
work on your career side your income
side to be able to address the 27 before
we can even talk about helping with the
80 unless I'm missing the math am I
missing
something no definitely not and that's
been my struggle because with my degree
being so specific with Health Sciences
my goal was to further my education and
go to PA school um and then I worked in
medical office for about two years and
decided that I didn't want to to further
my career in it in that
direction um you're going to have to
work on the career side of your equation
I don't think spending six figures on PA
schools to move right now let's clean up
the mess first the answer to your
question is you can't take your parents'
burden you don't have the strength to
mathematically